un très précis une esquisse avant de
peindre au bout du crayon en manche et
antoine fontaine peintre décorateur
depuis presque quarante ans vous
travaillez sur les techniques de
l'époque
oui oui bah oui ça c'est vraiment le
propos des métiers d'art en tout cas que
je représente cette année s'est montrée
cette technique qui est très ancien qui
a disparu il ya donc très peu de temps
d'enfin de génération une génération
avant moi qui a qui a des avantages
d'être quand on travaille par rapport à
des décors anciens on retrouve tout à
fait le geste et la technique
la technique c'est celle du travail avec
des pigments de l'eau et de la colle de
peau de lapin la journée du peintre
commence toujours c'est l'expression
fait chauffer la colle c'est vraiment ça
on doit commencer par chauffer chauffer
la colle obama risque qui prend une
bonne demi heure pour pouvoir la joindre
à la couleur antoine fontaine l'apprend
de son père peintre lui aussi il voulait
peindre grand pour le spectacle en 2005
il participe à la création des décors de
marie antoinette de sofia coppola
c'est à ce moment que
jean paul roux c'est donc le responsable
du théâtre de la reine et de l'opéra
royal m'a demandé de compléter les
décors qu'il avait ici et puis il a une
superbe forêt dans lequel nous sommes
qui est de six séries 10 1837 qui est
splendide et le lointain et deux plans
de chasse y étaient manquants et m'a
demandé de les recréer ça que ça n'est
pas de la restauration
je fabrique des des objets nouveau c'est
plusieurs répliques ce week-end antoine
répondra aux questions des visiteurs du
trianon et pourquoi pas déclencher des
vocations